very very big week Bernie Sanders today
will be officially releasing his
Medicare for all bill we've been
covering this for a while it started
with Bernie Sanders saying he would
propose a Medicare for All single-payer
bill we then learned that California
Senator Kamala Harris would be
co-sponsoring it we then learned that
Massachusetts senator Elizabeth Warren
would be co-sponsoring this bill and
even in advance of the release of the
bill today by Bernie Sanders we've had a
growing list of co-sponsors in fact
we'll put the list up on the screen for
our television audience this is a list
that I believe is accurate as of two
minutes ago although there's a there's a
number of senators I'll tell you after
who have expressed support for the bill
but have not indicated they would
formally co-sponsor Tammy Baldwin from
Wisconsin Richard Blumenthal from
Connecticut Cory Booker Kirsten
Gillibrand Kamala Harris mazie Hirono Ed
Markey the other Massachusetts senator
the other guy as he's known Jeff Merkley
Bernie Sanders of course Brian Schatz I
mentioned Elizabeth Warren and Sheldon
Whitehouse also Al Franken Patrick Leahy
jeanne Shaheen and Martin Heinrich again
have expressed support not clear if they
will co-sponsor so a few thoughts on
this if you look at that list of
senators that are co-sponsoring really
only Tammy Baldwin in Wisconsin is in
what could even be remotely called a
swing state from the people who are
co-sponsoring so yes the criticism that
this is a low risk thing for these
senators to do Democrats in blue states
when there's no chance we're getting
Medicare for all because Republicans
control everything right now it's sort
of a political gimme and that's fine I
don't disagree with that but I still
think that this is very very important
and we will do a full analysis of the
specifics of the bill hopefully tomorrow
hopefully tomorrow we will have
everything the way generally speaking
that this is expected to work is that
Americans under 18 would immediately
obtain universal Medicare cards and that
Americans not currently eligible for
Medicare would be phased into the
program or over a four-year period this
is the way we sort of expected it to be
Pat although I still want to look at the
detail
because there were rumors over the last
couple of weeks that this would not be a
true single-payer program that it would
be a Medicare expansion that would still
contain multi-payer aspects to it but
once we see the bill we'll know that's
the great thing we can read the bill
yeah it's great to see that Bernie
Sanders is having such an influence on
the Democratic Party now you know it's a
shame that he lost his presidential bid
sure but look at the long lasting
consequences of his run now not only do
you have support for Medicare for all
yes you also have the fight for 15 he
has 31 co-sponsors in the Congress and
officially became part the Democrats
officially say they are for $15 minimum
wage or are they the new flat form now
it's gone from 12 and then you also have
free college being introduced in New
York and all across the country and of
course the term free being used sort of
loosely we understand that nothing is
truly free night right we're not talking
about tuition in public universities yes
and paid for through taxation and other
other means as far as the connection to
employers for healthcare under under
Bernie's bill and employer provided
health care would be replaced the
employers would still pay a higher
payroll tax or tax of some sort but they
would no longer be required to provide
the insurance to the employees you would
still have private insurers right if
people continue to prefer private
insurance or they want to have private
insurance for elective treatments if
private insurance will cover those
treatments they will be free to do so I
do have a question about the strategic
aspect of this Republicans have been
beaten at down and up and all over the
place on health care multiple failed
attempts to repeal Obamacare and to
replace it with terrible ideas is this
proposal from Bernie simultaneously
something that will not pass anytime
soon and something that gives
Republicans an opportunity to say hey
forget about the failure of the aah a
look at crazy Bernie and his free stuff
that he's offering and sort of to shift
the attention over to Bernie Sanders
but as Medicare for all becomes more and
more popular in the polls though I don't
think that attack is going to hit very
hard don't you think I think it depends
on the
which that's used that the language that
Democrats use most Americans agree that
government should provide a basic level
of care for everyone so the specifics of
Medicare for all are not actually that
controversial yes
taxes you would be paying taxes employer
would be paying taxes the individual
would probably also be paying more taxes
but compare it to Canada right Canada
has such a system as what is being
proposed here the average American paid
eleven thousand three hundred and
sixty-five dollars in taxes last year
the average Canadian paid nearly fifteen
thousand dollars in taxes right about
$3,300 more than the average American
but the average American paid twice as
much for health care as the average
Canadian and that's what people often
don't get the long-term benefits will
outweigh the individual short-term
increase in taxation and it will
eventually save the average person money
that's the key it is the best plan on
the table and I think that's why
Democrats have to push for it also
because health care is going to be a
central issue in the 2018 races in 2020
yeah and you can't just run on this idea
of protecting the Affordable Care Act
especially as premiums continues to rise
especially as providers continue to pull
out you have to have a solution not just
say oh we'll keep what we have in place
because it's better than the Republican
alternative and to be clear what your
the criticisms you're pointing to of the
Affordable Care Act they are not
inherent to the Affordable Care Act in
other words the entire system is
experiencing what you're describing and
of course the Affordable Care Act is a
program that provides health care to
many millions of people who didn't have
it but it still is fundamentally working
within the same paradigm there's no
telling how much higher those premiums
would be if the Affordable Care Act
wasn't put in place right presumably the
within Affordable Care Act plans have
seen smaller increases in pricing
although that is something that
Republicans would take issue with so now
how about the senators that are
co-sponsoring right yeah it's true it's
not risky for them like I said everybody
but Tammy Baldwin is in safe blue states
Tammy Baldwin in Wisconsin it'll never
pass now it's just an easy political
gimme that doesn't really mean anything
I disagree that it means nothing we've
never had this level of public Senate or
you'll support and maybe I'm naive right
but I actually do believe that this
matters but I think ultimately it's
gonna be the public that quote gets this
done if it ever will be done it's great
Wow
I punch my mic because I'm just so
excited it's that great it's great that
we have 12 senators saying hey I am
gonna jump on board and co-sponsor this
and more senators who might co-sponsor
or at least say they support the bill
it is Americans that need to put the
pressure on constantly call write email
fax telegram smoke signals whatever it's
a pain but it's worth it I'm reminded of
just recently Republican Senator John
McCain killed the Affordable Care Act on
the Senate floor well the reality is it
was all the people that showed up they
made their voices heard that they didn't
want this and McCain was reasonable
enough to hear that it's the people that
need to activate here I am convinced of
that
and hey pat on the back to every senator
who's co-sponsoring but it's the people
that need to put the pressure on and I
hope that they will the video you just
finished watching was made possible by
you through the membership program you
can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership